Your pelvic organs are held in place by muscles
and tissues in your pelvis.
If these muscles and tissues weaken or tear
your pelvic organs may prolapse, or drop down,
into your vagina.
If your bladder and urethra prolapse into
your front vaginal wall, you have a cystourethrocele.
Your doctor may recommend an anterior colporrhaphy,
during which the surgeon will make an incision
in your vagina, push the organs back into
place and suture the tissue to help keep the
bladder in place.
If your rectum bulges into the back vaginal
wall, you have a rectocele.
You may need posterior colporrhaphy, during
which your surgeon will make an incision in
your vagina, push the rectum upward, and suture
the tissue to support the area.
Vaginal vault suspension repairs the prolapse
of the pelvic lining and the small intestine
into the upper vaginal lining called an enterocele.
Through a vaginal incision your surgeon will
push the small intestine back into position
and attach the top of the vagina to strong
pelvic ligaments.
If you have a prolapsed uterus, your surgeon
can repair it using laparoscopic instruments.
Your surgeon will insert a lighted camera
into your lower abdomen to view your pelvic
organs on a video screen.
Using special tools, your surgeon will lift
and support your uterus by suspending it from
ligaments at the base of your spine.